hey ah now I'm already off [ __ ] track
you know my [ __ ] Bank did to me I
walked in I had this account in New York
that I kind of uh was a little checking
account that had a little bit of money
in and I'm signing notice they were
taking some fees out I'm like well that
shouldn't be so I get to New York I walk
in I talked to the douchebag who works
there and he goes yeah they taken $27 a
month out I don't know why that is
here let me check to see what's up check
on his thing and he goes yeah we
shouldn't have been doing that and I go
okay well can you refund the money they
go absolutely and I go well well you
know I've had the account for like six
years
can we see how long you've been doing
this and he's like I'm sorry are our
records only go back for four months
really it only goes back for four months
it's amazing because my bank records at
home go back the entire time I've had
the account that's incredible and I just
have some piddly some in there while you
deal with hundreds of millions of
dollars if not billions if not trillions
I don't know what the [ __ ] you have I
just know there's a [ __ ] Bank of
yours in every goddamn state now but of
course it only goes back like four
months so I go alright well what if I
bring my records in I look him over and
I find out how long you been doing it
and then like now he can only refund it
for four months I'm like dude what are
you talking about and he goes well the
bank kind of looks at it like that that
that was on you what do you and I was
like it's on me
to not to not be like paying attention
to make sure the people are supposed to
be keeping my money safe aren't [ __ ]
stealing from me and he's sort of like
laughed I'm like dude this isn't funny
this is ridiculous you guys just stole
from me and if you've been doing it for
six years
what's that two hundred seventy bucks
and another [ __ ] now fifty like
almost three hundred bucks a year for
six years that's like 1,500 to 1,800
bucks somewhere in there and the guys
just sitting there [ __ ] laughing and
you know this is a usual [ __ ] yeah we're
gonna sue us go ahead we'll take some of
that bailout money which is part of your
tax money and we'll [ __ ] so I don't
know what I'm gonna do I'm gonna close
out the account and and I don't know
what do I do then I go across the street
to one of the vent for banks that are
left if anybody out there is in banking
how do I get my money
back beyond the four months because I
know that they've been doing it longer
than this can anybody explain that you
know this is why people this is why you
don't put a hundred percent of your
paycheck into the [ __ ] bag you got to
look at it this way if somebody mugged
you last week would you walk up to the
same person and take your paycheck and
stick it in their back pocket you
wouldn't would you
but for some reason we had these [ __ ]
bankers yeah I know III think everybody
should turn like I don't know everybody
should have a [ __ ] safe that you have
buried somewhere everybody's got a gun
and anybody can blow anybody away I know
it's all [ __ ] up [ __ ] [ __ ] guys
sitting there [ __ ] smiling nobody
sitting there doing he's doing that
little twirly thing you know that math
people do with their pens and people
were into finances I think they do what
to hypnotize you as says the guy's
[ __ ] sitting there telling me that
they've been stealing thirty bucks a
month from me and all I'm doing is I'm
trying to focus on him I keep looking
down at his silver shiny pen some sort
of mind trick fortunately I was aware of
it how am I said can you stop twirling
your [ __ ] pen but I didn't want to do
that because I was trying to keep my
cool which obviously is a difficult
thing for me to do you know I know right
now bill it's just 27 bucks a month
times how many [ __ ] people
you remember Superman three when Richard
Pryor stole half a cent from everybody
the next day had a [ __ ] Ferrari these
[ __ ] are taking 27 bucks a month from
everybody I'm convinced of it that's the
[ __ ] mob I swear to god the mob went
legit or those there will be blood guys
they are the [ __ ] [ __ ] and run
the goddamn banks he's [ __ ] concert
just stealing from me and there's nobody
getting nobody's gonna help me what am I
gonna go down there I'm gonna get that
guy he used to be on the [ __ ] Leave
It to Beaver what the [ __ ] was the name
of that show Maybury I always hated that
show that old Kant walking around with
her falsetto voice and a you know you
know what that show lacked somebody that
I wanted to bang that's why I didn't
watch it
there was nobody [ __ ] on it that was
the brilliance of the
stirs that they were like this is gonna
be hilarious we're gonna turn [ __ ]
Frankenstein into Drac and Dracula into
these kooky characters and it's all
gonna be funny but they knew at the end
of the day there had to be somebody that
the male demographic would want to [ __ ]
so they came up with that girl who was
allegedly ugly why am i explaining this
classic show you know the deal and she
looked like Marilyn Monroe and that's
what kept me in there I don't know
alright Batman after a while it's like -
what is going on with this 40 year old
guy in his ward and then all of a sudden
they had Catwoman walking around that
[ __ ] Hori outfit is she the one who
started that [ __ ] did women not dress
like [ __ ] on on Halloween before
Batman or Batgirl or Catwoman Catwoman
was a bad one right there's such
pathetic [ __ ] you don't I mean it's we
take off that [ __ ] ridiculous outfit
go stand behind a wall and start talking
to people and let's not how many people
even [ __ ] pay attention to you they
don't cuz you got nothing to say all you
can do is just dress up your goddam [ __ ]
and start strutting around the [ __ ]
place that had nothing to do with
Catwoman had nothing to do with her head
do with me [ __ ] getting [ __ ] over
by that goddamned bag [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] so now I gotta go down
there I gotta go down there like like
some [ __ ] guy whose buttons store
just failed after 75 years you know
Frankie fishface and Sons
remember those [ __ ] those businesses
when you were a kid it was always
something something and Sons you know
and like a lot of the times the kids
were forced into the business you know
some Italian guy he opens a [ __ ]
prosciutto shop and then that's it's
like an arranged marriage except it's
your job then you got to show up but I
have been working in the restaurants it
that was a deal they did that you know
they don't know [ __ ] about anything else
so everybody wanted to strike out on
their own and now look everybody ends up
with a [ __ ]
cubical working for these [ __ ] [ __ ]
who are stealing my money that's
uplifting isn't it